welcome our next speaker Ernest Frankel
who will talk about system biology
they're computer science engineering and
biology meet
hi so as Monty Python likes to say now
for something completely different I'm
gonna talk to you about biology not
computer science but I'm gonna show you
how the algorithm is of the type that
being developed here at MSR have really
had the potential and the effect of
having a big impact on how we understand
biology but for those of you from the
math or computer science background I
might have called this talk biology
looks hopelessly complex it's gonna get
worse before it gets better
and you'll see what I mean let's let's
start with what apparently is a simple
disease it's a disease called
Huntington's and you don't have to be a
neurobiologist to be able to tell the
difference between the brain of a
patient who does not suffer from having
tens on the right and the brain of the
patient with Huntington's on the left
tremendous loss of brain structure
therap now the origin of the disease is
the mutation in a single gene and so you
would think that this would be case
where we could really understand how
mutations cause disease and therefore be
able to figure out how to cure disease
but this mutation has been known for
approximately twenty years and it's led
to no effective cure and certainly a no
effective cure but not even infective
treatment that's because the effective
biological molecules exist screening the
complex a single gene when mutated
affects lots and lots of biological
processes and the traditional approach
is the studying these diseases are not
getting us the kinds of answers that we
need and so in systems biology what
we're trying to do is make a whole
series of very systematic measurements
of what goes on in the cell pretty much
any property we can effectively measure
you want to measure and then use compute
a computational approaches to build up
relatively coherent views of what all
those data mean and allow us to
understand how signals transfer through
different parts of the cell and where we
might be able to go and intervene and
cure diseases what things can we measure
well since the genomic revolution now
that we can measure sequence lots and
lots of genes we can measure the
expression of lots of different genes in
an organism we can measure lots of
things about proteins we can measure
lots of things about metabolites and we
can try to collect all of these
different data together and so these
different genomic proteomic omics
technologies have the benefit of being
comprehensive but they also have some
severe severe deficiencies when we look
at multiple different kinds of data
apply to the same problem well what we
typically find is that they don't tend
to tell us the same story
here we've got a sort of yellow data and
blue data and green data representing
different technologies is applied to the
same biological problem and you see the
Venn diagram doesn't overlap very much
and that's a difficult problem when
we're trying to understand what's going
on we also have a lot of false positives
and false negatives in these data what
we try to do in this Omega approach is
to try to understand how all of these
data could really arise from a single
biological process and so in this
cartoon you've got some cell surface
receptor on the outside of cell
detecting its environment and it sends
information into the cell and talks to
lots of different proteins and then
those proteins can send information down
into the nucleus where it can change
gene expression and we might find you
know the the blue technology tells
mostly about one kind of protein one
kind of process and the yellow
technology tells us more about another
kind of process but there is some
underlying physical reality and so we're
going to turn to algorithmic approaches
particularly graph theory to see if we
can discover what those apropos
commonalities are what the underlying
biological process is that gave rise to
these apparently the disparate data but
the problem this is where the gets worse
before it gets better is that when we
try to do that we end up with these
network structures that are just too
complex for human beings to understand
and so we need to come up with
algorithms that allow us to find the
interesting part of all these many
interactions among hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of different proteins and
genes and so what we've done is turn to
a class of algorithms called prize
collecting Steiner trees and in this
approach we have nodes and edges the
nodes represent either proteins or genes
and the upper at the edges represent
potential interactions among these
proteins or genes physical interactions
and then we try to find a subset of the
data from say the genes and proteins
that we think are changing in the
disease state indicated by the color the
yellow and the green that are connected
to each other possibly directly but
possibly through these hidden nodes
proteins and genes that we didn't
measure in our experiments because our
experiments aren't perfect but are never
less important for the disease process
and so when we apply this prize
collecting Steiner tree algorithm it
takes that very complicated graph and
finds a sub graph that's most important
for the biological in problem of
interest and the algorithm can try to
decide whether some data point which
there lies on the edge our graph is
so relevant that it has included or
whether it's likely to be a false
positive and should be excluded now when
we do this on real biological data then
we can get insights into what the
context are of the genes that we detect
is being relevant to the disease so here
we've got a bunch of yellow proteins
that are functioning in similar process
and we can then learn what kinds of
processes are going on and we can also
find nodes in these networks that are
very central and might be places where
drugs could be used to target this
altered process and restore health to
the organism so an example where we've
actually started to apply this it's
something called glioblastoma it's very
devastating brain tumor it's usually
diagnosed at a late stage the only
treatment really is surgery combined
with chemotherapy without a patient's
survived very very short times with this
treatment they survive usually a year or
less so the treatment is obviously not
very good so we've taken a model of this
disease where we have one gene that's
been mutated that's very common mutation
in the glioblastoma and we're looking at
the effect of that gene on the rest of
the cell we've collected all these
different omics kinds of technologies
and we've built a graph from those data
and in this graph the red nodes are ones
where there's experimental data and then
the circles that don't have color in
them are ones that the algorithm is
telling us are most are also relevant to
the disease and when we look at this we
immediately can decompose into sub
graphs that tell us a lot about the
biological processes involved some of
those are ones that are rich in red
those are ones where there's a lot of
experimental data and some of them have
a lot of clear circles those are ones
where the algorithm is telling us that
they're relevant to the disease process
but the experimental data by itself
would not have led us in those places
and so that can lead us to new
hypotheses as to what to look at and the
other thing that's extremely exciting
about this is now we can find potential
new drug targets and we can do that by
looking for the nodes in this network
that are most central so the single most
central node in this particular network
is a protein called sark and actually
it's been shown that if you target sark
and the mutation that is is affecting
these particular cells so the EGF
receptor mutation those two mutations
I'm sorry
targeting those two proteins
simultaneously has a very strong effect
on blocking the growth of these tumor
cells and so that is a potential for
combinatorial therapy to be much better
than individual treatments one and the
after the other
and now we can start working our way
down this list of most central nodes and
do experiments so this was an expected
result our next of most central node was
something was very surprising to us it's
a gene that doesn't seem to have any
known biology associating it with
glioblastoma but we can actually go into
the laboratory now and test whether
treating that node with the drug has an
effect on the growth of these tumor
cells and sure enough we can stop growth
of these tumor cells with that and if we
combine that treating that node with the
most the node at the top of the network
we actually get more than an additive
effect on blocking the growth that these
tumor cells and so what I hope I've been
able to give you a taste of is that we
can take these incredibly complicated
biological problems where we don't know
how to come up with treatments and do
very systematic measurements through all
these different kinds of omics
technologies and then apply the kinds of
algorithms developed here at MSR to
really develop models that allow us to
directly go and decide what to test
experimentally and hopefully lead us to
new ways of treating disease the work
that I described you is largely done by
the three women on the top left Carol
Huang s see a girl Ottoman Lori burr in
my laboratory with a lot of wonderful
collaborations from people out of mighty
shown on that side of the graph and at
MSR here as well thank you very much
okay thank you honest for the wonderful
talk and we have time for question I
encourage people to please go to the
microphone unless you have a one-word
question you can shout because if he has
to repeat three sentences it takes a
while nobody can you tell us what the
special protein you found was yeah so
when when Carroll first showed me the
results of this computation I told her
oh this doesn't look too good because
the second most central note there is
the estrogen receptor which I'm sure
most of you know about estrogens being a
female hormone and it has no obvious
relationship to brain tumors but
actually turns out that glioblastoma is
much more common in men than women and
so we had a little bit of hope that
maybe this wouldn't turn out to be a
total red herring and sure enough our
experiments in laboratory seems to be
confirming that at least in this cell
culture model of what's going on we can
block the growth of these tumor cells
and maybe someday it'll lead to an
effective treatment as well yeah so you
said that things are going to get much
more complex before they're gonna get it
simple I'm wondering if there's a sort
of a middle ground possible where you
use very complex algorithms come up with
a hypothesis which may even surprise
everyone but then once you have the
hypothesis there are simpler algorithms
to confirm the validity I mean how much
can you trust this very very complex
algorithm in its output that's that's a
great question and I don't think we can
trust it in the sense of a hundred
percent confidence what the goal of this
is from my perspectives is leading us to
do better experiments so if we start
with the whole human genome the whole
human proteome we have too many possible
things to test we can't we can't explore
all the possibilities by using these
algorithms we can focus in on the parts
of the the proteome where we could
actually try to do experiments and if we
are success rate is one in ten that's
still better than one in 20,000 okay so
that's all I'm sure Shawn to your
question has to be one name one word
though right
what diseases do we focus on and what do
we do with these targets when we find
them so we've been focusing a number of
different diseases some of them are
chosen because they're devastating and
anything we can make progress on would
make a big difference so Huntington is
something we work on our lab Global
awesome I've told you about some of them
are extremely common ones like type 2
diabetes which is a becoming much more
common in the developed world with
increasing obesity and these are
diseases where people have tried to do
all the obvious experiments so taking a
completely unbiased view might lead us
in very different directions and
potentially have a very big payoff what
do we do with the results well the
primary thing we do with them is try to
get them out there to a larger community
to community so we do some experiments
in our laboratory to test and try to
find the most most plausible things but
then the goal is to really expand this
knowledge and send it out to other
people can confirm it in other models of
diseases and then hopefully the
pharmaceutical industry pick it up as
well okay let's thank analysts again